steve à lille se présente en ce qui
concerne le choix des différentes modes
d'expression pour ne pas dire par à peu
près comme l'année dernière c'est à dire
que nous avons le cinéma de films
inédits dont 1
nous avons des présentations de
créations de théâtre dramatique et dès
ce soir
dès le premier jour une création celle
de wilson avec son tnp est une pièce de
bandes donc la peinture donc le cinéma
donc le théâtre dramatique dans les
concerts et uniquement des concerts
comprenant des oeuvres de compositeurs
du xxème siècle sûrement dans de la
musique contemporaine
la chapelle du palais des papes
transformer tout cet été en galerie
d'art
mais c'est pour accueillir le prince de
la peinture de notre temps pablo picasso
les princes chacun le sait ont toujours
eu tendance à se placer au dessus du
code de la morale ordinaire picasso
n'échappe pas à la règle et même
accompagné du carré blanc
bon nombre des toiles qui figure à
avignon ne serait être présenté à la
télévision devant elle s'il vient un
moment aux lèvres des jeunes visiteuses
un sourire un peu gêné
très vite la fascination du maître agi
emporte toutes les réticences et rend
ridicule les fausses pudeurs
on a l'impression me disent tous les
visiteurs d'entrer dans la tête une
picasso puisqu'aussi bien cette
exposition comporte toutes les oeuvres
de picasso pendant la période de 1969 et
les premiers mois 2009 170 et je crois
que c'est ce qui est important
précisément dans cette exposition
camp rock de retrouver tout le
développement d'un certain nombre de
thèmes familiers de picasso premier de
ces thèmes
le couple l'amour physique inspiré
picasso un rêve tumultueux et truculent
qu'il traduit par une profusion
hallucinante d'image jaillit très
certainement sous son pinceau dans un
état de tension créatrice fulgurante au
milieu de cette tourmente
une exception quelques rares toile ou
tout à coup dans l'expression se
découvre chez l'homme une sorte de
tendresse protectrice et chez la femme
l'extase quelle force impulsive ghz le
bras de picasso pour faire naître les
singuliers personnages de sa mythologie
ces figures d'une inhabituelle
inexplicable beauté
deuxième thème les mousquetaires erreur
déconcertant que picasso définit ainsi
c'est peut-être vous ce sont tous les
hommes épris de courage que leur
solitude leur désenchantement
transfigurant mousquetaires m permanent
enfin chez picasso l'enfant loiseau ici
aussi
rien ne retient les élans de jeunesse
triomphante du vix artistes
rien ne bride son invention volcanique
c'est audace jusqu au supplice de cette
colombe même dont il a fait un de ses
plus éloquent symbole